salvador dali été opéré aujourd'hui
pendant quatre heures et demie les
chirurgiens ont pratiqué une greffe de
peau sur le peintre qui à 80 ans il
avait été gravement brûlé le 30 août
dernier au cours d'un incendie survenu
dans sa chambre à coucher
cette opération était sa dernière chance
sinon il était condamné les deux
prochains jours seront décisifs pour cet
homme qu'il a fallu à rich arraché à son
château où il vivait cloîtré depuis
trois ans
guelmous lake ce vieil homme enturbannés
qui se cache c'est la dernière image du
peintre alors qu'on l'emmène à l'hôpital
il a fallu enregistré son consentement à
l'opération devant notaire pour éviter
toute contestation
la presse espagnole en fait ses choux
gras triste mise en scène autour de
cette porte fermée pour ce clown génial
qui exhibait en permanence son goût de
la dérision faction une de ses dernières
apparitions publiques en 1981 il est
déjà atteint semble-t-il de la maladie
de parkinson et en 82 il perd gala sa
compagne depuis 50 ans sa femme son
égérie
sa mère depuis vivait reclus dans son
château
refusant même de s'alimenter il aurait
perdu ainsi plus de 35 kg remous rire
parce qu'il ne trouve pas d'issue à sa
vie et il a une épouvantable peur de la
mort donc il vit
un chemin de croix absolument
incendiaires cet homme qui a passé sa
vie me l'a dit souvent 10 veut
désespérément croire en dieu n'a jamais
n'est jamais arrivé à croire en dieu et
tout d'un coup il vit comme un espèce de
chemin de croix comme un christ un peu
paillasse mais un peu génial et moi ce
qui m'intéresse dans dans ça et ce qui
me navre est ce qu il me fait une infime
en paix ne s'est pas les dollars qui
sont en jeu c'est pas les scandales qui
sont en jeu c'est que la presse et en
particulier la presse espagnole se
combinent pas c'est extrêmement beau
minable avec lui c'est qu'on assiste à
l'agonie atroce donnant de grande
qualité tout au long de sa carrière le
dernier des grands c'est réaliste a
organisé sa vie comme une provocation
masquant ainsi l'essentiel cet accident
dramatique qui touche cet homme de 80
ans va peut-être gommer l'image
caricaturale qu'il tenait à imposer
nous rappelons à temps que c'est un des
plus grands peintres de notre époque qui
est menacée
non